Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Heute war ja Wahl. Hattest du die Wahl? Was hast du gewählt?
Ich sagte doch nicht, was ich gewählt habe. Was war das denn jetzt?
Die haben heute in dem Wahllokal, die haben den Ablauf falsch gehabt.
Ich bin da hingekommen, hab denen meine Wahlbenachrichtigungskarte gezeigt,
dann hab ich einen Stimmzettel bekommen.
Ich dachte so, der hat mich jetzt gar nicht von der Liste der Wählerinnen gestrichen.
Dann kam ich aus der Kabine zurück mit meinem Stimmzettel gehe zu der Urne und
dann steht da halt der Typ mit der mit der Liste wo die Namen stehen wo er mich
abstreichen muss und sag ich so ja,
was mach ich jetzt ja zeigen sie mal her und nehmen sie meinen Stimmzettel ich
so, den geb ich ihnen nicht,
achso ja ne sorry, haben sie einen Personalausweis weil normalerweise hätten
wir gerne die Wahlbenachrichtigung.
Ich so, habe ich. Kann ich Ihnen gerne zeigen.
Wahlbenachrichtigung gezeigt. Ja, gut.
Ja, dann gucken wir jetzt das, was Sie hier mal wegstreichen.
Dann können Sie den Stimmzettel da in die Urne werfen.
Tut mir leid, dass ich den gerade nehmen wollte. Das wollte ich natürlich nicht nehmen.
Dem war schon auch klar, dass er da gerade so an den falschen,
potenziell an den falschen hätte geraten können. Mitgeben Sie mal den Stimmzettel.
Fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz gut. Aber das war jetzt als Intro-Gang wahrscheinlich zu lang, ne?
Wir sehen Martin noch die Hoffnung. Ich krieg das so wie geschnitten.
Du machst das doch schon eine Weile.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Fangen wir wieder neu an oder du machst jetzt die Musik?
Oh Mann, das fängt ja gut an.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 484 vom 11.
Februar 2024 und man verlernt mit der Zeit ja alles, sogar Sendungseinstiege.
Ich hab dir gesagt, mir fällt zu weich ein.
Ja, jetzt lassen wir das so, oder?
Ich hätte noch andere zur Auswahl gehabt von ChatGPT.
Die waren nicht witzig.
Ja.
Ich dachte, ich.
Kann ja keinen Qual-der-Wahl-Witz machen oder so. Das ist ja zu abgedroschen.
Tja.
Ja, wir hatten Wiederholungswahl in Berlin.
So sieht es aus. Ja.
Und es ist keiner hingegangen.
Ich war gerade ein bisschen verwirrt von deiner Reihenfolge.
Also ich meine, erst kommt man noch mit der Wahlbenachrichtigung an. Ja.
Die haben das falsch gemacht.
Aber du meintest gerade, als erstes müsstest du von der Wählerliste gestrichen werden.
Das ist ja tatsächlich erst, wenn du die Stimme abgibst, dann wirst du gestrichen.
Okay, dann hat er das gemacht. Dann hat er es richtig gemacht.
Ja. Bei mir war jetzt der Prozess ein bisschen anders, weil ich hatte eigentlich
Briefwahl beantragt, die dann aber nicht wahrgenommen. Und dann musste ich ja
erstmal durch den Prozess durchgehen.
Dann musst du durch den Prozess der Ausstellung eines neuen...
Dann musste ich das Material, was mir zugesendet wurde, also den Wahlschein
und so weiter, den musste ich dann, naja, sie haben gesagt, ich muss den jetzt vernichten.
Ja, okay. Und wie mache ich das jetzt ordnungsgemäß?
Feuerzeug.
Ja, wussten sie dann erstmal auch nicht so richtig. Ja, das müssen sie irgendwie da hinten machen.
Dann bin ich zu diesen anderen Vögeln gegangen, da wo man dann eigentlich seine
Stimme abgibt, also seinen Stimmzettel abgibt.
Und ja, müssen sie jetzt vernichten. Ja, so weit habe ich das schon verstanden.
Die Frage ist, was ist der korrekte, ordnungsgemäße Vorgang?
Muss ich das jetzt anzünden? Das haben sie mir nicht gesagt.
Ich habe nur gefragt, ich wollte ja sozusagen den Prozess nicht in Gefahr bringen.
Ja.
Das weiß ich, dann mache ich irgendwas falsch.
Du machst den falsch kaputt und dann kann man den nicht mehr richtig kaputt machen.
Ja, dann ist das wieder so ein Schmetterlingsschlag.
Oder der ist schon kaputt und die hätten aber vorher noch...
Ja, also ich hatte einfach Angst, dass die ganze Welt auseinanderbricht,
wenn ich jetzt nicht das Richtige tue.
Also wenn man schon eine Wiederholungswahl macht, möchte man ja jetzt auch nicht...
Dabei alles falsch machen.
Ja, noch was falsch machen.
Dann waren es wieder die Wähler, ne?
Ein drittes Mal.
Ja. Ja. Nee, es war alles ganz reibungslos. Es war allerdings auch wenig los.
Ja.
Also ich tippe mal...
Ich glaube auch, deswegen haben die da... Die waren wahrscheinlich völlig geschockt.
Unterfordert. Ja. Deswegen habe ich ja ihnen gleich eine Aufgabe gestellt.
Naja, ich habe es dann auf jeden Fall geschafft und der Stimmzettel ist dann
irgendwann in der Kiste gelandet. Und jetzt ist alles anders.
Also mein Eindruck war, dass das da schon grob lief. Ich habe zum Beispiel...
Gecheckt, ob da auch wirklich die Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten draufstehen, die ich erwarte.
Das war ja bei einem Wahllokal vor zwei Jahren so, dass sie innerhalb einer
halben Stunde gemerkt haben, dass sie vom falschen Wahlkreis die Zettel ausliegen hatten.
Dass dann irgendwann einer hingegangen und meinte also ich wollte eigentlich
jemand anders wählen, aber der ist nicht auf dem Zettel,
können sie mal gucken ob das die richtigen sind, weil auf meiner Wahlbenachrichtigung
und so steht ja hier Wahlbezirk und so,
und dann, hier hängt ja auch überall irgendwie so einer, aber der steht hier
nicht und dann haben die haben die gesagt, oh Oh, ha!
Ja, und es ist natürlich auch lustig mit denen, die zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gewählt hatten.
So ein Durcheinander. Also da ist echt alles schief gegangen.
Zur Erinnerung, das war jetzt hier die in Berlin völlig verkackte Bundestagswahl
und auch Landtags- oder Senatswahl in Berlin.
Letztere wurde ja schon mal nachgeholt. Das hat uns ja dann hier die tolle,
Verkehrssenatorin eingebracht, die jetzt erstmal wieder alle Radwege verhindern muss und so.
Und du weißt schon hier, sie hat jetzt übrigens gemerkt, dass das irgendwie
mit dem ähm, dass das mit dem Magnetschwebezoch, dass das schwierig ist.
Ach was?
Ja. Da wäre so viel, da würde so viel dranhängen irgendwie, das wäre tatsächlich
ein bisschen schwierig.
Da haben sich schon ganz andere Städte dran verhoben.
Man wählt da Leute und vor allem Politiker haben dann oft ja bei den meisten
Leuten so dieses, naja, die stellen sich ja zur Wahl, die müssen ja auch irgendwie kompetent sein.
Und das ist einfach ein Trugschluss. Also nicht, dass sie nicht intelligent sein können.
Ich habe schon Politiker erlebt, die sind intelligent, aber meistens ist es dann doch so.
Das, ja, wie sagte Pavel mal so schön, die hätten auch manchmal Probleme einfach mit Mathematik schon.
Also einfach Grundrechenarten wären teilweise schwierig zu vermitteln gewesen.
So Prozentrechnung und so Sachen, das würde einfach so nicht verstanden werden da.
Und das ist schon mal so ein Teil des Unglücks.
Ja, naja, also wir haben jetzt auf jeden Fall beide nachgewählt,
weil wir beide in so betroffenen Wahlbezirken waren.
Das ist ja nicht überall in Berlin, sondern es ist nur in ausgewählten,
nur in den feinsten Bezirken, wo die speziellen Leute wohnen.
Da wollten sie es dann doch nochmal genau wissen.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Wir sitzen ja hier früher morgen und haben keine Ahnung.
Aber Spoiler, es wird sich nicht füreinander durch. Ich.
Habe es ehrlich gesagt, also ich muss sagen, die war ja auch ein bisschen unterberichtet.
Also mich wundert das überhaupt nicht, dass diese Beteiligung jetzt niedriger ausfällt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie niedriger ausfällt, nur als ich da war,
war nicht viel los. Das heißt ja erstmal gar nichts.
Naja, wenn man jetzt so die ersten Berichte so anschaut,
ist die Wahlbeteiligung wohl relativ gering und jetzt irgendwie meine Kontakte
in den Wahllokalen sagen auch, dass es eher langweilig ist.
Tja, wenn ihr was Spannendes machen wollt, dürft ihr euch nicht für die Demokratie einsetzen.
Naja, gut. Neue Betätigungsfelder gibt es ja auch bei der Bahn.
Hast du das mitbekommen?
Ja, da gibt es...
Kennst du dich da aus eigentlich? Hier MS-DOS und Windows 3.11.
Ja, da habe ich...
Hast du Erfahrung?
So wie du auf alten Schiffen lernt man das Segeln.
Ja.
Und habe ich gemacht, ja. Ja.
Was hast du gemacht da auf MS-DOS? Was können Sie da vorweisen, Herr Neumann? Ich.
Glaube, ich hatte einmal ein
altes Laptop, da war glaube ich so MS-DOS 3.8 oder sowas, kann das sein?
Das wurde noch von Disketten gebootet, der Rechner hatte noch nicht mal eine Festplatte.
Aber mein erster richtiger Rechner, den ich auch davor hatte,
dieses alte Laptop, habe ich dann irgendwann mal aus historischen Zwecken wieder gestartet.
War glaube ich MS-DOS 6.2 war das so die?
Und dann musste man Win eingeben, damit Windows 3.11 startete.
Habe ich hingekriegt. Mhm.
Okay, super.
Und also lief Doom drauf, also hatte ich den Rechner, würde ich sagen, vollständig im Griff.
Mit 3D sozusagen. Okay, ja dann kannst du bei der Bahn anfangen,
ne? Die suchen jetzt da Leute.
Windows 3.11 für Workgroups. Ja.
Alles geil. 3.11 für Workgroups, dieser Name allein, ne?
Das ist jetzt kein Witz, ne? Also...
Nicht die Bahn, sondern konkret Siemens. Die Bahnabteilung von Siemens sucht
einen Admin für Windows 3.11, für Workgroups.
Und wir dachten euch, wir dachten uns so für euch so als Jobangebot,
vielleicht ergibt sich da ja nochmal was.
Für so Leute, die auch dann Schwierigkeiten hatten, dann mit der Entwicklung mitzuhalten.
Ja, weil IT ist ja schon so ein schnelllebiges Feld.
Und es stimmt ja auch. Und dann irgendwann zu sagen, nee, komm,
Schuster, bleib bei deinen Leisten.
Mit einem alten Pferd bringst du keine Tricks mehr bei.
Nee.
Hund sagt man, ne? Mit einem alten Hund bringst du keine Tricks mehr bei. So war das.
Aber wenn du das richtig unterkommst. Ich frage mich, wie du sowas sicher betreiben
willst, aber das haben sie auch direkt dazu gesagt, dass es in der Bahn üblich
wäre, dass Dinge länger betrieben werden und dass sie selbstverständlich sicher betreiben.
Ach ja, ich habe, muss ich sagen, wenig Erfahrung mit Windows 3.11 für Workgroups,
da war meine aktive Windows-Zeit schon lange vorbei.
Die war nämlich nur sehr kurz, ich habe nämlich eigentlich nur Windows 1.0 verwendet
und das auch nur zu einem einzigen Zweck, um damit PageMaker zu starten.
Das war eigentlich die einzige Anwendung, die ich als unter Windows verwendet habe in all der Zeit.
Ne, ich glaube, ich bin ja relativ spät dann zu Mac gegangen und ich habe dann
schon relativ, ich glaube zu Windows 95 Zeiten habe ich so Dualboot Linux gehabt schon.
Aber ich musste natürlich irgendwie bestimmte Programme da einfach,
insbesondere die ganzen Spiele, musste es natürlich unter Windows laufen lassen.
Und nicht unter Wine.
Spiele, Windows.
Meinst du mit den Angaben kriegen wir den Job?
Also du hast Chance nicht.
Ich glaube.
Ich halte mich da raus.
Lilo.
Ich glaube, ich mache weiter Podcasting.
Mit dem Lilo habe ich dann Dualboot gemacht. Der Linux-Loader.
Der Linux-Loader, genau.
Wow. Alright. Na gut, wisst ihr, wo ihr noch einen Job kriegt jetzt.
Ja.
Genau. Aber wir wollten uns ja eigentlich über netzpolitische Aspekte unterhalten.
Deswegen möchtest du jetzt über Raumzeit reden, oder was?
Ah ja, stimmt ja, genau. Da war ja noch eine Hausmitteilung.
Ja.
Genau. Also heute, wie sagte ich gerade, ist 11. Februar.
Und das bedeutet in 10 Tagen gibt es eine Möglichkeit meinen anderen Podcast
mal live mitzuerleben wenn ihr Lust habt, ich mache,
eine Aufnahme on stage und da kann man so drumrum sitzen und in die Ferne schauen weil das Ganze im,
Zeiss Großplanetarium wie es korrekt da also heißt in Berlin stattfindet,
da kann man sich dann ein Ticket klicken und sich hinsetzen und ich habe einen
Gast und das ist Ulf Merbold, das ist so ein ja, so ein, ja, das ist einer der,
erfolgreichsten Astronauten Deutschlands, so, dreimal im All gewesen und so
und nach Sigmund Jähn, der zweite.
Kommen übrigens beide so mehr oder weniger aus der gleichen Ecke,
das ist echt interessant, also man muss da schon so aus Thüringen,
Erzgebirge, das ist der Ort, wo die, wo die Ursuppe der deutschen Astronauten herkommt.
Aber der ist dann in hat im Westen rüber gemacht, weil er nicht Physik studieren
durfte. Deswegen ist er dann westdeutscher Astronaut geworden.
Im Westen rüber gemacht und dann ins All. Also jemand, dem es grundsätzlich
einfach nicht gefällt, wo er ist.
So ein Meckerer. Naja, hast du jetzt goldener Westen alles rüber und dann so, ah ne.
Ah scheiße.
Boah.
Ich muss hier weg.
Auf in den Orbit.
Naja. Genau.
Wie alt ist er jetzt?
Wie alt ist er?
Also auf jeden Fall schon Rente, Baujahr 1941.
Also ist er gar nicht mehr als Astronaut tätig?
Nein, nein, der ist jetzt 80 Jahre alt.
83, 82, 83.
Ja, da kann man dann auch, also Astronaut ist ja auch eigentlich ein anstrengender
Job, da kann man dann auch einfach mal in den Ruhestand gehen.
Ja.
Okay, und der erzählt dann, wie sie damals...
Genau.
Mit Windows 3.11.
Föber-Groups. Genau.
Würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr dabei seid. So, jetzt aber Inhalt.
Genau, auf der europäischen Ebene wird ja der AI-Act diskutiert.
Und es ist so ein skurriles Feld irgendwie.
Es gibt jetzt eigentlich eine relativ klare ursprüngliche Positionierung,
die auch das Parlament hatte, nämlich die gesagt hat, hier, wir möchten bitte
keine biometrische Echtzeitüberwachung haben,
wir möchten auch so Emotionserkennung,
also im Prinzip diese ganze biometrische Massenüberwachung, das möchten wir
eigentlich nicht haben.
Und dann kam die spanische Ratsvorsitz, der ja nun auch wirklich irgendwie hier
relativ oft negativ auffällt und hat gesagt, ja nee, machen wir doch,
wir haben ja eine gute Idee, danke für eure Position, liebes Parlament,
wir schreiben da jetzt mal wieder was rein und möchten halt eher schon so etwas drin haben.
Ja, also möchten diese ganzen Sachen in der biometrischen Überwachung eher wieder drin haben.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie sich das weiter entwickelt.
Es ist ja wirklich immer so eine komische Sache.
Also vielleicht muss ich mir da irgendwann auch nochmal einen ordentlichen Zeitstrahl
malen lassen, wann so etwas, wie dieser Prozess wirklich läuft,
wann da mal die endgültige Abstimmung ist.
Aber auf jeden Fall biometrische Echtzeitidentifizierung, Emotionserkennung
und sowas bleibt da weiter im Rahmen der Diskussion.
Auch wenn eigentlich schon stabile Positionen dagegen bestanden im EU-Parlament
und die Mitgliedstaaten im Rat das jetzt irgendwie anders sehen.
Und eine andere spannende Sache finde ich, also es geht natürlich hier um die Sicherheitsbehörden.
Also hier geht es jetzt, kannst du dir genau anschauen, wir machen da so ein
AI-Act, dann geht es einmal darum,
okay, müssen wir gucken, was macht denn die Wirtschaft so, was können wir der
Wirtschaft untersagen und die Wirtschaft muss eben eigentlich Register führen
über besonders risikoreiche KI-Systeme.
Also wenn du irgendwie, das ist dann definiert, was jetzt besonders risikoreich
ist, Entscheidungstreffen, besondere Überwachung oder so.
Und für den Staat selber, da kommt natürlich dann wieder so eine andere Sache.
Sagen wir erstens, ach ja, hier so biometrische Massenüberwachung,
das können wir eigentlich mal den Sicherheitsbehörden erlauben.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Und eigentlich, wenn die riskante KI-Systeme einsetzen, dann erfassen wir das
zwar auch in der Datenbank, aber im nicht öffentlichen Teil.
Weil muss ja nicht unbedingt jeder sehen, dass wir bei Strafverfolgung,
Migration, Asyl und Grenzkontrollmanagement riskante KI-Systeme einsetzen.
Aber das können wir jetzt, das ist ja witzlos, wenn wir dann das in der Datenbank
schreiben müssen, dass wir die eintragen.
Deswegen sagen wir, da schaffen wir keine Transparenz drüber.
Also erkennbar hier wieder so Last-Minute-Wechsel für, ach lass uns mal diese
ganzen Überwachungsvorzüge dann doch mal für uns Staaten freistellen und uns erlauben.
Während ja, dieses ganze Ding ja eigentlich geritten wird unter Jetzt-Licht,
aber hier mal die EU den Konzernen mal die die mal entketten,
dass die hier nicht ungezügelte,
KI-Überwachung hier ausrollen und ja, ehrlich gesagt finde ich das ein bisschen
sehr erstaunlich, was da, wie das da jetzt irgendwie gerade läuft.
Dann gab es irgendwie so so einen komischen offenen Brief, der mich auch eher ein bisschen.
Ja, wie soll man das sagen? Ratlos zurückgelassen hat nämlich der AI-Act-Verabschiedenbrief,
den dann irgendwie ein paar Organisationen unterschrieben haben.
Wir haben irgendwie so Bertelsmann Stiftung, Stiftung Neue Verantwortung,
Verbraucherzentrale, Bundesverband, aber auch einige, also irgendwie eine komische
Liste, wo irgendwie so steht so, ja der fehlende Rechtsrahmen ist das größte Problem.
Und wenn da jetzt einzelne Sachen nicht so gut dran passen, dann soll man trotzdem.
Jetzt mal unterschreiben.
Wir, die Unterzeichner, unterstützen nicht alle Maßgaben der Verordnung.
Vielmehr sehen sie an verschiedenen Stellen Verbesserungsbedarf.
Aber wir müssen jetzt gemeinsam Position beziehen, um die Zukunftsfähigkeit
Deutschlands und Europas zu sichern.
Also habe ich auch jetzt ja üblicherweise, sagst du in deinem offenen Brief,
ja, folgendes hätten wir gerne noch geändert und dann Volldampf voraus,
aber hier offener Brief an die deutsche Bundesregierung,
stimmen Sie für den AI-Act.
Und natürlich klar, würde der nicht angenommen werden, dann wäre das ein hohes
Risiko für die Innovationskraft und den Grundrechtsschutz in Europa mit internationalen Auswirkungen.
Also die Sorge, die sie in diesem Brief benennen, ist,
dass ein Flickenteppich aus Regulierung in Europa entstehen könnte und dann
damit Innovationskraft gedämpft wird,
weil sich dann hier nicht die europäische AI Startups hier ordentlich durchsetzen können.
Die haben ja auch überhaupt keinen, also die haben ja jetzt gerade so richtig
eine Vollgas-Position und überhaupt keine Nachteile dadurch,
dass sie keine Daten haben oder dadurch,
dass es dieses Thema eigentlich nicht gab. Irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch.
Also ich denke diesen AI-Act es wäre schon sehr schön wenn wir.
Wenigstens uns darüber einigen könnten keine massenhafte biometrische Überwachung
zu haben und auch keine Rückschlüsse dafür und als allererstes mal sich der
Staat selber ein paar Ketten anlegt,
aber es scheint hier eher andersrum zu sein das überzeugt mich nicht.
Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen die Gefahr, gerade mit so Riesenpaketen,
also AI, das ist halt auch so mega generisch.
Ah, künstliche Intelligenz, ja ach das Thema, das regulieren wir jetzt mal.
Dabei ist das einfach so ein riesiges Fass, was man da aufmacht und das zeigt
sich ja hier an den Detailverhandlungen schon, welche Aspekte es dabei gibt.
Aber dadurch, dass das dann alles in einem dicken Teil durchgerollt werden muss
und das ist generell auch so ein bisschen das Problem der europäischen Ebene.
Also wenn Europa mal was anfasst, dann muss das gleich so ein Riesenpaket sein
und alle Einzelaspekte müssen da drin untergebracht werden und dann wird es
halt auch schnell mal zu viel und vor allem verliert man so ein bisschen dann auch den Fokus,
was war es jetzt eigentlich nochmal,
warum sind wir jetzt eigentlich überhaupt angetreten das zu regulieren?
Also was war jetzt eigentlich genau der Grund?
Und ich habe manchmal auch so den Eindruck, dass solche Sachen,
die am Schluss über die am meisten noch gestritten wird, ursprünglich mal so der Trigger waren.
So nach dem Motto, oh, da gibt es ja Gefahren, da müssen wir mal wegen der Gefahren,
müssen wir mal was machen.
Dann wird da zwei Jahre drüber geredet und dann wird das immer mehr so,
ja die Gefahren, aber auch die Chancen, wir müssen ja auch die Chancen sehen
und wir müssen ja unsere Innovationskraft behalten, wir müssen ja zukunftssicher
sein und jetzt brauchen wir hier mal Rechtssicherheit und dann so,
was wollten die alles machen?
Achso, ihr wollt ja eine klare Regelung für die Verwendung von biometrischer
Erfassung. so, ja dann machen wir das doch mal, da schreiben wir wir sind doch
sowieso gerade dabei bei so einem AI-Act, das passt doch eigentlich ganz gut, oder?
Und dann steht einfach genau das Gegenteil von dem drin, was man eigentlich
haben wollte und das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd und das halt auch
mal alles richtig zu tracken und zu verfolgen, das ist natürlich die Aufgabe
der ganzen Begleiter und NGOs und vielleicht auch von uns hier ein bisschen.
Aber es ist halt schwierig wenn das alles so groß ist und dann vor allem dann
eben die Auseinandersetzung innerhalb von Europa und dann natürlich auch noch
mal innerhalb der europäischen Institutionen so verbissen dann geführt wird.
Und das Parlament, der Trilog.
Da hast du wieder irgendein Land, was aber unbedingt alles überwachen will und
das fängt dann an rumzudrohen.
Da wüsste ich auch ganz gerne mal, wie es da hier eigentlich aussieht,
welche Staaten sich hier eigentlich noch so einbringen.
Du hast halt einfach so ein paar potenzielle Staaten, die sagen wir mal so mit
Repressionstechniken nicht ganz so Berührungsprobleme haben.
Also Beispiel in Argentinien hat kürzlich dieser Javier Millet,
glaube ich spricht man den aus.
Der hat gesagt, ja hier, wer hier protestiert, dem kneifen wir vom Sozialsystem ab.
Also kriegt ihr erstmal Hartz-IV-Sperre, wenn ihr eure Zeit so verbringt. So ungefähr.
Also Diskussionsstand ist, dass viele die Position vertreten,
ja, wir haben das ja jetzt, die Echtzeiterfassung biometrischer Natur,
die haben wir ja jetzt hier verboten.
Und deswegen ist ja gut, aber Retrograd kann man ja schon dann machen.
Also wenn die Aufzeichnung, wenn es nicht in Echtzeit ist, dann ist es erlaubt.
Wir haben ja fünf Sekunden gewartet.
Genau das ist es nämlich. Und da gibt es dann auch keine Grenzen dafür.
Das heißt, bei Bagatelldelikten, bei der Demonstration gab es einen Handtaschendiebstahl,
wir machen jetzt mal vollständige biometrische Aufklärung, Retrograd,
das wäre also hier gedeckt.
Und jede Ausnahme, jede kleine Ausnahme wird natürlich dann sehr breit und sehr groß.
Oder wenn du keine Grenze hast, was für Straftaten oder so.
Du könntest im Prinzip sagen, du verfolgst Obdachlose wegen Hausfriedensbruch.
Diese Massenüberwachung, du guckst ja nicht einzelne Gesichter an.
Das könntest du ja ohnehin jetzt schon machen.
Und schon heute ist es ja so, dass in Deutschland Tausende identifiziert werden
mit Standardgesichtserkennungssystemen.
Und ja, das klingt erstmal nicht so übermäßig tragisch, aber das ist halt am
Ende, wird der öffentliche Raum dann so überwacht wie das Internet.
Wie das Internet heute von irgendwelchen Trackern erfasst und verfolgt wird.
Und das ist sicherlich keine so, also das ist schon sinnvoll,
dass Reclaim Your Face und so sich da stark entgegensetzen, weil das wäre jetzt
wirklich mal etwas, wo man sagen könnte,
das wäre sinnvoll so etwas nicht zu haben oder so etwas starke Grenzen zu setzen.
Anderes Beispiel, in zwischen 2018 und 2020 gab es mehr als 400 Verfahren gegen
Polizistinnen, die Datenabfragen missbraucht haben.
Wow. Also.
Wir hatten ja hier im Logbuch mit Edelbeider auch eine Betroffene von diesen
Datenauskünften zu Gast.
Und, also man kann jetzt, diese Anzahl war mir übrigens auch echt,
also ich wusste, dass es viele, und das sind ja nur die Verfahren,
das sind ja nur die Fälle, die bekannt sind.
Mit anderen Worten, muss ja davon ausgehen, da gibt es ja eine fürchterliche
Dunkelziffer, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Dass solche Überwachungsinstrumente in den Händen der Polizei nun wirklich nicht
so gut aufgehoben sind, wenn sie nicht mit starken Kontrollmöglichkeiten versehen sind.
Und nicht vergessen, da geht es nicht nur um die Datenabfragen,
da geht es dann auch um die ganzen Drohbriefe des NSU 2.0.
Also da sind wir nicht mehr im Bereich, der lustig ist.
Also da geht es weiter drum herum. Ich denke, diese KI-Erkennung sollte wirklich
stark eingeschränkt werden.
Und erst recht sollte das, was Staaten da machen, transparent sein.
Also diese beiden Forderungen, die kann man schon mal so stellen.
Die finde ich jetzt nicht sonderlich überzogen.
Ja, kann man auch mal drauf bestehen. Ja.
Es gibt natürlich auch positive Aspekte.
Es soll dann eine nationale KI-Aufsichtsbehörde geben, wo du dich beschweren kannst.
Das kann potenziell schon ganz sinnvoll sein, dass du überhaupt auch Möglichkeiten
hast, dich diesen automatisierten Entscheidungssystemen oder so, die zu kritisieren.
Predictive Policing also irgendein System sagt ja, wo die Polizei hinfahren
soll, das kommt mir auch irgendwie wirklich eher lächerlich vor,
da könnte also eine Eingrenzung stattfinden,
ja das mit den Hochrisikotechnologien finde ich auch nicht schlecht, da wäre halt,
sinnvoll, wenn das für alle gilt Ja, also es war nicht alles schlecht,
aber die wirklich, wo man sagen könnte, das sind jetzt echt mal Dinge,
die man mal durchziehen könnte, da wird natürlich schon jetzt wieder gebohrt.
Tja, wie immer.
Gut. Soviel zum AI-Act. Dann kommen wir doch mal zu den Gefahren von AI.
Die nehmen nämlich tatsächlich zu.
Und ich glaube, das wird hier auch nochmal ein immer wiederkehrendes Ding.
Kennst du die Chefmasche?
Also ich kenne das nicht unter dem Begriff, ich kenne das als CEO-Fraud oder
Fake-President, aber ja.
Fake-President, ja auch nicht schlecht, genau. Also darunter versteht man so,
dass in Hackerkreisen nennt man die Technik ja eigentlich Social Engineering.
Also wie bekommt man jemanden dazu etwas zu tun, was die Person eigentlich unter
normalen Vorzeichen so nicht tun wollen würde.
Das ist so wie, wenn amerikanische Late-Night-Shows mit dem Mikrofon auf die
Straße gehen und die Leute nach ihren Passwörtern fragen Ja,
haben sie Passwörter und so?
Ja, ist ihr Passwort auch sicher? Ja, mein Passwort ist sehr sicher.
Ja, woraus besteht denn ihr Passwort?
Ja, ich habe den Namen meines Hundes und meinen Geburtsdatum.
Ja, wie heißt denn Ihr Hund?
Ja, Piffi Ach, wann sind Sie denn geboren? Ja, am 23.05.
So
Und.
Das ist so, du stehst da davor und denkst dir so, ah okay, das war ja einfach
und tatsächlich kann man das glaube ich an sich selber auch ganz gut festmachen.
Dass man eigentlich, wenn man so emotional gerade irgendwie so in so einem gesettelten
Modus ist, der Welt ja eigentlich auch immer mit Vertrauen gegenüberstehen möchte.
Ja. Das ist schon auch ein Wunsch von uns allen. Wir wollen eigentlich gerne
allen vertrauen. Wir wollen das Böse nicht sehen.
Wir wollen das Gute im Menschen sehen. Und das Problem ist nur,
das Gute im Menschen ist zwar auch in der Welt, aber es gibt ja auch Leute,
die sind der Meinung, sie könnten sich vielleicht an dir bereichern,
indem sie vielleicht mal nicht ganz so gut sind.
Naja und diese Chefmasche ist halt so eine Technik, mit der man einfach sich
irgendwelchen Mitarbeitern eines Unternehmens gegenüber als Vorgesetzter ausgibt,
zum Beispiel per E-Mail oder per Telefonanruf und dann drängt man sozusagen auf sie ein,
so ja hier tu mal bitte folgenden Vorgang und wenn dieser Vorgang dann halt
mit Geld zu tun hat, dann wird es spannend.
Und jetzt ist gerade ein Fall bekannt geworden, der sich in Hongkong abgespielt
hat, bei einer im Bericht nicht weiter genannten Firma mit vielen Mitarbeitern.
Und dort wurde ein Mitarbeiter per E-Mail auch erstmal angeschrieben und dann
vor allem zu so einer Videokonferenz eingeladen mit weiteren Führungskräften.
Und die Videokonferenz, die fand auch dann statt und in dieser Videokonferenz
legten so diverse Führungskräfte des Unternehmens so ihre Gründe da,
warum jetzt dieser Mitarbeiter doch
bitte mal eine Reihe von Überweisungen einleiten sollte, 15 an der Zahl.
Und dann wurden die dann auch in der Folge von diesem Mitarbeiter durchgeführt.
Das war jetzt nicht ganz wenig Geld, das war irgendwie so 200 Millionen Hongkong-Dollar
sind hier im Gespräch, das sind so 23,
24 Millionen Euro ungefähr und ja, das Problem war halt nur,
dass in dieser Videokonferenz,
sich überhaupt gar keine richtige Person befand. Also all diese ganzen Führungskräfte,
die er dort gesehen hat, sahen zwar aus wie Führungskräfte und hörten sich auch
an wie Führungskräfte, aber es waren tatsächlich alle AI-generierte Fake-Personas sozusagen.
Die Berichte, die ich jetzt so gelesen habe, sind ganz so einig darum,
wie das jetzt so genau abgelaufen ist.
Aber man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass hier Bildmaterial entweder aus internen
oder vielleicht auch einfach aus öffentlichen Videos genommen wurde.
YouTube, irgendwas, Company-Videos und so weiter.
Irgendwo tauchen ja dann diese Personen auf und wir wissen auch mittlerweile,
wie wenig es an Trainingsmaterial braucht,
um eine Person halbwegs glaubhaft dreidimensional in anderen Posen wiederzuspiegeln
und vor allem auch etwas anderes sprechen zu lassen.
Und wir hatten ja auch hier selber vor ein paar Sendungen Herr Bundeskanzler und Frau Alice Weidel,
die ja hier auch klare Botschaften an die Hörerschaft von Nockbuch-Netzpolitik
gerichtet haben und da sieht man eben, die Werkzeuge sind da.
Also etwas, was noch vor zehn Jahren so ein bisschen total future-mäßig war,
sind mittlerweile einfach solche Werkzeuge, die jetzt auch Kriminellen zur Verfügung
stehen und wenig überraschend, sie nutzen sie es auch.
Also dieser Mitarbeiter hat diese Personen auch visuell wiedererkannt und auch
von der Stimme her wiedererkannt, also er war sozusagen, wusste diese Personen gibt es.
Allerdings ist das schon alles so ein bisschen fakey gelaufen,
also es gab da jetzt keine wirkliche Interaktion, es war jetzt keine.
Realtime-Impersonifikation Brauchst du ja.
Auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Genau, die haben einfach das so, ja, guten Tag, stellen Sie sich mal vor,
wer sind Sie denn hier, Sie sind doch hier der Untergebene und so identifizieren Sie sich mal,
und dann so, ja, jetzt mal bitte hier Folgendes tun und das wurde dann halt
einfach abgelesen also man kann davon ausgehen Vielleicht.
Hast du auch einfach ein, zwei echte Personen drin, die die er halt dann nicht
kennt und ein paar vorbereitete Schnipsel von den Führungskräften,
die halt einfach, was weiß ich, daneben sitzen und nicken oder so.
Vorgeschobene Assistenten zum Beispiel, die dann die Interaktion machen.
Oder sagst du hier, so, und nach dieser Einleitung übergebe ich dann jetzt mal
an den Projektmanager Michael, der das jetzt hier kurz nochmal erzählt,
worum es heute geht oder so.
Also du musst ja, ja eigentlich einige wenige Sätze völlig generischer Natur,
die vielleicht auch im anderen Kontext schon mal gesagt wurden.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du sowas hin mit gutem Schnitt und noch nicht mal Deepfake.
Irgendwie, dass du mal jemanden filmst in einer Videokonferenz,
wie er da sitzt oder so. Ein paar Sachen sagt dir, der dann irgendwie in einen
anderen Kontext schneidet.
Also, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass du da jetzt keine sonderliche Technologie brauchst.
Nee, und vor allem gerade Gerade in diesem schwierigen vorgesetzten Situation,
vorgesetzt zu untergeben, gerade wenn jetzt so eine Videokonferenz ist und du
schickst vielleicht wirklich einem, diesem Mitarbeiter, unbekannte Person als
Assistenten und als Gesprächsleiter vor.
Du fängst ja dann nicht an als kleineres Licht, könnte sich bitte mal hier der
CEO, der hier angeblich ist,
mal wie man so einen Personalausweis bei der Videoidentifikation so nach links
und nach rechts drehen muss, damit irgendwie das Hologramm ein bisschen aufleuchtet.
Möchtest du dann vielleicht auch, dass diese Personen mal so bewusste Positionen
einnehmen, die vielleicht von so einer AI nicht ganz so gut gefakt werden?
Lassen sie doch mal ihr Haar fallen.
Vor allem interessant ist, dass der Typ ja offenbar ursprünglich ...
So ein bisschen skeptisch war und gesagt hat, ey, das kommt mir irgendwie alles komisch vor.
Und dann wurde er mal spontan in die Konferenz reingeholt. Dann sitzen da die
ganzen Gesichter und sagen, wie, sie wollen die Überweisung nicht machen.
Was ist das denn? Ja, genau.
Peer Pressure. Und das ist übrigens ein Phänomen, das sehr häufig vorkommt.
Diese Fake President Sachen. Ja, also auch, also das kenne ich jetzt so aus
dem Wirtschaftsumfeld schon mehrere Unternehmen, die so etwas mal berichtet
haben oder wo es auch mehrmals passiert ist.
Ja, dass dann irgendwie mal bei der einen Niederlassung, mal bei der anderen
und dann natürlich jetzt nicht im Bereich, also nicht immer im Bereich von Millionen,
aber so im Bereich von ein paar hunderttausend kommt das dann doch recht häufig mal vor.
Ja, das muss auch nicht mal der Präsident sein. Also wenn man sich Zugang verschaffen
will, da hilft auch mal ein Blaumann und eine Werkzeugtasche.
Das wirkt bei vielen Leuten auch schon sehr überzeugend.
Wo ist denn hier der Wasserschaden?
Eigentlich kommst du ja überall rein, wenn du ein Funkgerät in der Hand hast.
Du zeigst einfach nur mit der Antenne dahin, wo du jetzt hin willst.
Ja, oder auf den Kongress-Chaospost.
Diese Überweisung ich meine, die haben schon immer sehr gute Cover-Stories,
zum Beispiel auch irgendwie so, ja wir machen jetzt hier einen Merger hat sich
denn PwC schon bei dir gemeldet?
Nee, haben sich nicht und dann baust du quasi,
mit mehreren Personen im Prinzip so eine Erwartungshaltung auf,
weil da meldet sich auf einmal PwC ist halt was ganz anderes als jetzt scheiße,
haben die sich immer noch nicht bei dir gemeldet.
Naja gut, warte mal, dann hauen wir jetzt mal rein. Und dann irgendwie sowas
wie, ja, damit wir hier, also da und da gelten vom Financial Regulator recht harte Bedingungen.
Und damit das nicht als Insider-Trading gilt, müssen wir jetzt über die privaten
E-Mails kommunizieren.
Wo dann nämlich quasi, was erstmal ganz gut ist, weil jetzt bist du auf einmal
der Kriminelle. So, oh, Insider-Trading, nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Dann lassen wir lieber private E-Mails machen. Ich meine, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn mein Chef mir sagen würde, wechsel mal auf private E-Mail,
das ist hier Insider-Trading, da würde ich sagen, frage mal lieber jemand anders.
Aber das ist natürlich kein schlechter Trick dafür zu sorgen,
dass du halt auf einmal so ein bisschen Unrechtsbewusstsein hast.
Dass du froh sein kannst, dass die so nett sind, dir bei deinem Insider-Trade zu helfen oder sowas.
Da siehst du dann, wenn man mal die Gelegenheit hat, solche Fälle aufzuarbeiten,
schon sehr elegante psychologische Techniken. Die haben alle schon ihren Mitnick gelesen.
Dann regt man sich immer so über Bürokratie auf, das Einhalten von Regeln besteht,
um irgendeinen Vorgang auszulösen.
Dabei sind genau diese Regeln oft auch so ein Schutz.
Ja, das muss von Personen sowieso unterschrieben werden, das muss nochmal vorgelegt
werden, bevor das nicht wieder zurückgekommen ist, kann ich hier gar nichts machen und so.
Also da wird man ja auch schnell mal so, ja das muss doch mal auch hier und
ich muss doch mal ganz schnell und ich brauche das jetzt auch und so.
Ja, man möchte gerne immer die Flexibilität für sich selber haben,
aber sieht natürlich selten den ganzen Prozess.
Ja, also der Mitarbeiter kann einem natürlich sehr leid tun,
er hat es ja dann am Ende auch selber gemerkt, aber er ist halt ordentlich bearbeitet worden.
Also auch nach der Videokonferenz ging das dann noch ein paar Tage weiter mit
E-Mail, mit Instant-Messaging, es wurden auch nochmal 1 zu 1 Videocalls nachgereicht.
Wie die dann im Detail gelaufen sind, weiß ich jetzt leider nicht.
Das war in den Berichten jetzt nicht so drin.
Und es dauerte dann so eine Woche, bis er irgendwie richtig Verdacht schöpfte.
Da waren aber die Überweisungen eben schon getätigt.
Dann hat er nochmal bei seinem eigenen direkten Chef nachgefragt,
was denn damit auf sich hat.
Und dann so, ja nee, keine Ahnung, wovon du redest, was hast du gemacht?
Ja, das ist dann halt irgendwie so, ja, wow, da fühlt man sich bestimmt nicht gut dabei. Nee.
Also da fühlt man sich nicht nur nicht gut dabei, das hat dann regelmäßig auch
psychologische Konsequenzen, dass die Leute eine längere Zeit arbeitsunfähig sind.
Oder bist du einen Job los, weil du gegen Regeln verstoßen hast,
also es kann ja alles mögliche sein.
Tja ja, also bei der nächsten Zoom-Konferenz, ne? ne?
Ich sag also.
Alter.
Ich hab gedacht, das war ein Deepfake, du hast mir doch nicht ernsthaft diese
Aufgabe gegeben. Bis Sonntag soll ich das machen?
Auf so eine Tricks fall ich doch nicht rein.
Jetzt hab ich erstmal einen Ausweis, ey. Kenn ich auch, kenn ich auch.
Dreh mal dein Ohr ins Licht, damit ich das Hologramm sehen kann,
was da drin abgedruckt sein soll.
Wie, du hast da keins? Ja, sorry, dann können wir hier leider nicht weitermachen. Vielen Dank.
Ja, aber Deepfakes zu kennzeichnen, bleibt ja so ein Bestreben.
Man sieht natürlich hier, dass es auch einfach überhaupt nichts,
nicht wirklich was bringt.
Aber es gibt ja, Meta hat jetzt gesagt, hier, wir möchten bei unserer KI,
die irgendwelche Bilder generiert, haben wir jetzt ein Verfahren,
dass wir im Prinzip kleine Watermarks in den Fakes unterbringen.
Und ich würde so sagen, das Thema kam wieder auf, weil es jetzt vor ein paar
Wochen irgendwie wohl auf Twitter,
das ist dieses ehemalige soziale Netzwerk, eine Reihe gab an,
ja, dann doch relativ offensichtlich wahrscheinlich Fake-Bildern von Taylor Swift,
die wahrscheinlich so nicht stattgefunden haben.
Man könnte Zweifel haben.
Also ich würde mal sagen, die waren wahrscheinlich fake. Und da gab es aber
natürlich keine, oder der Skandal war dann, oder skandalisiert behandelt wurde,
dass es Twitter nicht gelungen ist, das Pasten dieser Bilder zu verhindern.
Ja, was natürlich eigentlich, oder beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich Twitter einfach
dank Elon Musk auch kein Interesse daran hatte,
das Posten dieser Bilder zu verhindern und sich dann am Ende sehr ungelenkt
damit geholfen hat, dass Suchen nach Taylor Swift verhindert wurden.
Wo ich jetzt, wenn ich Taylor Swift wäre, auch sagen würde, sorry,
finde ich auch kacke, wenn man nach mir nicht mehr suchen kann auf eurer Plattform.
Lasst euch mal bitte irgendwie was Ernsthaftes einfallen, um das zu verhindern.
Jedenfalls, ja, Meta sagt also, sie wollen quasi unsichtbare Signaturen im Bild unterbringen.
Und irgendwie in die Metadaten was reinschreiben, damit man erkennen kann,
dass das ein Fake-Bild ist Das wird im Zweifelsfall für die,
sagen wir mal, für die Plumpen,
vorgehenden Reichen, ja, aber natürlich kannst du jedes, jede digitale Signatur
oder jedes Watermark, das du finden kannst, kannst du natürlich auch einfach wieder entfernen, ja.
Machst also irgendwie ein bisschen Rauschen in das Bild rein oder so,
dann wird das wieder weg sein. Also, immerhin.
Wollen sie da irgendwie etwas gegen unternehmen, aber ich glaube,
jede Methode, der Fake-Erkennung in sozialen Medien wird,
automatisch umgehbar sein und wenn sie es ist, ermöglicht sie denen,
die sie umgehen können, natürlich ein umso überzeugenderes,
Fake.
Wenn Meta sagt, hier, wir haben eine KI-Fake-Bild-Erkennung.
Wir markieren 99,9% der Fakes.
Und dann sagen wir hier, da machen wir nämlich einen roten Rand dran.
Dann sagen wir, Achtung, ist Fake.
Achtung, ist Fake. Dann ist der ganze Meter voll mit Achtung,
ist Fake. Und bei denen, wo es kein Fake ist, denkst du dir auf einmal einen grünen Rand.
Und dann wird natürlich diese Gefahr erhöht.
Auf jeden Fall kommt mir das klüger vor, als das Verfahren, also sagen wir mal,
die Kennzeichnung von KI-generierten Bildern kommt mir erstmal grundsätzlich etwas klüger vor,
als das Verfahren Originale zu signieren.
Weil, dass das nicht klappen wird oder dass diese Signaturzertifikate sofort
überall rumfliegen, halte ich für im Prinzip einfach selbstverständlich.
Also die Idee wäre dann quasi in die Smartphones und digitalen Kameras so ein
Echtheitszertifikat quasi mit einzubauen. Das geht nicht lange gut.
Ja.
Also erstmal auf den ersten Blick, ja klar, also könnte man tun,
sagen wir mal Apple könnte jetzt hier irgendwie da so ein Public Key nehmen
und damit sozusagen das unterschreiben oder ein Secret Key nehmen in dem Fall
und dann kann man es mit einem Public Key überprüfen.
So, ah ja, okay, das ist von der Software auf dem iPhone irgendwie erzeugt worden,
aber dann kommst du halt in tausend Probleme, was ist, wenn das Bild dann nachbearbeitet
wird, dann ist diese Information ja auch im Nullkommanix wieder weg,
abgesehen davon, dass halt dann irgendwann diese Keys auch liegen werden,
vielleicht nicht zuerst auf dem iPhone, aber dann eben auf diesen anderen Digitalkameras
oder was auch immer dann sozusagen noch daran teilnimmt und das wird einfach
nix werden, also das ist Quatsch und ob das dass andere funktionieren kann.
Das ist dann halt wieder so ein bisschen so ein Rattenrennen,
weil natürlich kann man so ein digitales Wasserzeichen ein erstmal nicht sichtbares, sondern von,
Meta selber auf Nachfrage überprüfbares irgendwie könnte man schon machen,
weil nur die wissen, wo sie gucken müssen.
Aber irgendwann wird man das auch wissen, wo man gucken muss und dann kann man
es auch wieder rausnehmen. Und dann beißt sich die Katze so ein bisschen in den Schwanz.
Ja, schwierig.
Ja, wir werden als Gesellschaft damit umgehen können müssen am Ende. Ja.
Aber der Vorteil irgendwie, also Taylor Swift kann natürlich jetzt auch,
hat jetzt eine plausible deniability,
sollten also dann doch irgendwann mal erotische Bilder von ihr auftauchen,
dann lehnt die sich einfach zurück und sagt, ja, egal.
Das werden ja eh Leute machen, das kann Taylor Swift und das kann jeder machen
Also diese Gefahr wird bleiben, aber ich glaube, das haben wir hier auch schon
ausführlich diskutiert, lass uns mal lieber über,
den Verfassungsschutz reden Echt?
Nicht über Taylor Swift?
Das finde.
Ich aber irgendwie spannend.
Kommt drauf an Mal gucken, was hier spannend ist Das ist ja sowieso ein Vorgang
Ich hab's ja damals schon gesagt,
da war der Maaßen glaube ich noch Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz,
was ja schon wirklich immer einfach sowas von irrsinnig war,
dass der Typ der Verfassungswächter sein sollte.
Und jetzt ist er da seit ein paar Jahren weg.
Und jetzt ist er führender Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Führender Verschwörungstheoretiker, also rechtsextrem.
Jetzt hat er dann noch seine eigene komische Partei da gegründet.
Wenn du mal anhörst, was der von sich gibt, also ist der wirklich absurd.
Und der wird jetzt vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz in der Kartei der Rechtsextremen geführt.
Die.
Führen den im internen Nachrichtendienstlichen Informationssystem als Rechtsextremist.
Nein, das sind zumindest keine Probleme, die Erkennungsdienstlichen Merkmale
nachzuschlagen. Die hatten sie wahrscheinlich schon.
Irre, oder?
Also sie haben,
also er hat dann glaube ich auch einen Brief hingeschrieben, ob das stimmt.
Dann haben sie ihm gesagt, Hier sind übrigens die Sachen, die wir gesammelt
haben, wo sie sich rechtsextremistisch verhalten haben.
Wo sie hier antisemitische Stereotype verteilt haben oder Migranten mit einer
Krebserkrankung verglichen haben.
Und das hat er dann irgendwie, ich glaube dieses Schreiben hat er dann auch
irgendwie veröffentlicht.
Und wehrt sich jetzt dagegen. Also es ist.
Sechs Jahre war der Chef.
Ja, das war ein Albtraum, dass so jemand,
als Verfassungsschützer da positioniert wurde.
Das war ja schon bei seiner Anstellung schon irre, so jemanden zu nehmen.
Aber es ist auch wirklich krass, wie der sich weiterentwickelt hat.
Und der einzige, wo der noch vorkommt, ist dann irgendwie solche Publikationen
wie Kompaktmagazin und Tichys Einblick, diese ganzen Ja, Rechtsextremen.
Krass. Aber allein der Vorgang, dass dein ehemaliger Verfassungsschützer wird
Rechtsextremist oder war eigentlich damals schon einer so ungefähr und wird
immer schlimmer verbreitet,
Verschwörungstheorien muss am Ende vom Verfassungsschutz überwacht werden. werden.
Das ist schon, ähm, das ist schon, finde ich, massig faszinierend,
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ja, ähm, fragt man sich vor allem, wer hat denn den, ist denn überhaupt auf
die Idee gekommen, den mal so an.
Diese Position zu bringen?
Ja.
War das nicht zu einer der letzten Sendungen schon kommentiert, dass er unter der äh,
Der müsste unter Merkel...
Hans-Peter Friedrich hieß der deutsche Innenminister zu dem Zeitpunkt und der
müsste ihn eigentlich vorgeschlagen haben, weil er fällt sozusagen in den Bereich rein.
Aber weil wir den Verfassungsschützer losgeworden sind wegen der NSU-2-Aktenschredder-Aktionen, ne?
Genau.
Also weil da Rechtsextremisten waren...
Brauchen wir jetzt mal hier den Maaßen.
Setzt ja mal einen gemäßigten Rechtsextremisten hin.
Ja, maßen, gemäßigt, das klingt doch irgendwie, das muss doch passen. Ja.
Wahnsinn.
Aber zum Glück unternehmen wir jetzt mal was gegen die Hacker.
Das sind eh die Schlimmsten.
Das sind die Schlimmsten. Und da wird jetzt auch wieder so eine,
diese UN-Cybercrime-Convention.
Ich habe auch noch nicht ganz verstanden, warum die da überhaupt irgendwie, also die haben einen,
also United Nations kennen wir, das ist die United Nations,
wo große Versammlungen, die haben dann irgendwie gesagt,
wir machen jetzt ein Ad-Hoc-Committee to elaborate a comprehensive international
convention on countering the
use of information and communications technologies for criminal purposes.
Also ein Autor-Komitee, um internationale Konventionen zu schaffen gegen diese
ganzen kriminellen Aktivitäten mit Informations- und Kommunikationssystemen.
Und insgesamt, die Taxonomie dahinter erinnert schon sehr stark an auch die
deutschen sogenannten Cybercrime-Diskussionen, wo es dann irgendwie...
Kriminalität mit dem Tatmittel Internet gibt. Also das sind Dinge,
die du auch ohne Internet machen könntest, aber dann mit der Hilfe des Internets
und eben ja, so richtiges Cybercrime, was nur geht, weil es das Internet gibt.
Und da wollen sie alles Mögliche machen.
Und da gibt es aber natürlich, sie wollen da jetzt die Fehler wiederholen,
die man eigentlich in Deutschland mit den,
Paragraph 220 2020 waren ja, glaube ich, die Hackerparagraphen schon falsch
gemacht hat. Ist das 2020, ja? Oder 2002?
202.
202, na, war klar. Also mit den Hackerparagraphen 202 auch gemacht hat.
Also es geht um, in Artikel 6 sagen sie im Prinzip so, ja, illegaler Zugriff wird jetzt verboten.
Und das haben wir jetzt in der letzten Sendung ja schon besprochen,
diesen Fall von Modern Solutions,
wo jemand, wo im Prinzip die Ausnahme fehlt oder einfach, dass man sagt,
jemand hat das in guter Absicht gemacht oder in good faith,
wo du also sagen kannst, ja, der hat ein Sicherungssystem hier umgangen,
Aber er hat die Sache gemeldet und das Sicherungssystem war nicht effektiv.
Es war nämlich eine Katastrophe und genau deswegen hat er es ja gemeldet.
Also genau diese beiden Fehler machen sie in Artikel 6 auch.
Es gibt also keine Ausnahme für, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man in gutmeinender
Absicht oder so, in nicht böswilliger Absicht könnte man eigentlich sagen.
Und das ist natürlich ein Problem für die
gesamte freie, freiwillige Sicherheitsforschung, so etwas nicht zu haben.
Und könnte dazu führen, dass dann eben die UN-Regelungen quasi nahelegen,
dass in allen Ländern genau das, was wir jetzt mit diesem Modern Solution Fall
loswerden wollen, zum Standard wird.
In Artikel 7 sagen sie, ja irgendwie mitschneiden von Traffic ist jetzt halt Illegal Interception.
Und auch das klingt natürlich aufs erste Mal sinnvoll, aber es ist natürlich
relativ üblich, dass du zum Beispiel deinen Browser aufmachst und dir mal den
Netzwerktraffic anzeigen lässt.
Oder mal Wireshark laufen lässt, um zu gucken, ob der Traffic hier verschlüsselt ist oder nicht.
Und das ist nämlich auch typisch, dass du im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit natürlich Traffic dir anguckst.
Das zu kriminalisieren, ohne den Zweck oder die böse Absicht oder die kriminelle
Intention irgendwie festzuhalten, ist natürlich auch ein Problem.
Und dann gibt es irgendwie bei Artikel 8 und 9 Interference with Data,
Interference with Computer Systems, da geht es dann irgendwie so,
Interference scheint eher so in diesem Bereich zu laufen, wenn das auf einmal
nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also wenn du jetzt auf einmal Denial of Service findest, ja,
falsch, durftest du nicht.
Und das ist natürlich auch wieder, sollte schon irgendwie gesagt werden,
muss einfach ein Satz rein wie mit krimineller Absicht oder mit Schädigungsabsicht.
Ja, dann kann man ja argumentieren, dass das nicht in Ordnung ist,
aber irgendwie sozusagen so, das Ding hat nicht mehr funktioniert,
jetzt bist du reif, scheint auch ein bisschen zu weit gefasst.
Und in dem Artikel 10, Misuse of Devices, da gibt es dann genau,
da kommst du dann und wollen hier die Hacker-Tool-Paragraphen wieder machen
und sagen dann auch so, Software, die das kann, Software und Systeme,
die das können und nicht, dass man die natürlich zu Testzwecken braucht.
Das ist ja die rechtliche Situation, wie die wir in Deutschland haben,
wo gesagt wird, diese Tools werden verboten und Benutzung oder Besitz oder Verbreitung
solcher Tools ist verboten,
weil man damit diese Straftaten begehen kann oder deren Zweck die Vorbereitung
einer solchen Straftat ist und das ist auch sehr sehr sehr ungünstig formuliert
und dass man natürlich für jede Schwachstelle auch ein Testtool braucht,
sollte eigentlich selbstverständlich sein.
Und dann gibt es noch weitere, eher im rechtlichen Bereich.
Es sind genau die Fehler von den Hackerparagraphen in Deutschland,
die sie da wiederholen wollen.
Und die ja bekanntermaßen in Deutschland jetzt gerade mal verhindert werden
sollen. Also wo man sagt, die müssen wir nochmal dran.
Das steht ja im Ampelkoalitionsvertrag drin, dass man sagt, da müssen wir mal
bei, dass wir da mal Rechtssicherheit und Klarheit schaffen,
die auch jetzt nicht so schwer wäre.
Dann sagen sie ja hier, die Verfolgung kann dann in mehreren Jurisdiktionen
verlaufen, was natürlich problematisch ist, wenn du jetzt für ein Problem durch
mehrere Jurisdiktionen gereicht werden kannst oder Angst haben musst,
dass nämlich genau nicht deine Sicherheitsforschung hier mal von den UN-Conventions
geklärt ist, sondern zusätzliche Rechtsrisiken entstehen.
Und dann haben sie ja noch in dem Artikel 28 Absatz 4,
im Prinzip so eine grundsätzliches Mitwirkungspflicht für alle,
die Ahnung von Computern haben.
Also jeder Vertragsstaat muss Gesetze erlassen, um seine Behörden in die Lage
zu versetzen, von Personen die Kenntnisse über das betreffende Computersystem,
das Informations- oder Kommunikationstechnologiegerät oder das Netzwerk oder
deren Komponenten haben und die Schutzmaßnahmen, dass sie von denen die erforderlichen
Informationen verlangen können.
Der Satz ist also relativ lang und heißt am Ende, jeder Staat soll Gesetze erlassen,
dass man Informationen von denen verlangen kann, die wissen,
wie das System funktioniert.
So ein bisschen so, Sie sind Arzt, dann müssen Sie jetzt hier auch diese Person retten.
Genau.
Lassen Sie mich durch, ich bin Hacker.
Und dafür muss es ein Gesetz geben, dass die Behörden dann ermächtigt,
das von dir zu verlangen.
Also nicht lassen sie mich durch, ich bin Hacker, sondern lassen sie mich wegrennen,
ich bin Hacker, weil die Behörden verpflichten mich hier sonst alles mögliche.
Ja, das ist ja nun wirklich absurd, weil ich meine, ob man kompetent ist,
das liegt ja nicht im Ermessen anderer.
Das ist nicht primär. Also wenn ich selber was nachweisen muss,
dann liegt es im Ermessen anderer.
Aber wenn jetzt andere einfach mal annehmen, ich wäre in irgendetwas kompetent,
ja das ist so ein bisschen so,
ich meine früher gab es ja auch so Fälle, wo so Leute einfach auch,
einfach was weiß ich, ob ihres Wissens bestimmte Dinge einfach zugetraut wurden.
Also man will ja schon eher.
Für die Daten, die irgendwelche Leute haben wollen, will man schon eher einen
Due-Process haben, wo man sagt, okay,
es gibt hier irgendjemand, der wacht über diese Daten und der hat rechtliche
Rahmenbedingungen, die erfüllt sein müssen. müssen zum Beispiel,
eine Ausbildung. Nee, ein Richterbescheid. Also eine, was weiß ich,
eine Richterin hat gesagt, du musst jetzt hier diese Daten rausgeben oder so.
Und die beruft sich auf ein Gesetz, das es gibt.
Das haben Leute, das kann immer noch gut oder schlecht sein,
aber da gibt es einen formalen Prozess.
Nicht, es gibt ein Gesetz, dass Behörden aus beliebigen Leuten die Kompetenz
sind, die Daten rausprügeln können.
Also das ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen weiträumig.
Ähm, ja, also äußerst komisch. Ich frag mich eh, warum das unbedingt bei der
UN sein muss, aber wahrscheinlich haben da auch einfach Leute gesessen und haben
sich gedacht, wir müssen jetzt auch mal was mit diesem Cyber machen.
Ja, warum sollen nur die anderen immer diesen Spaß haben?
Ja, warum gibt's da nicht von uns mal was?
Kanada.
Ja, ist auch so auf diesem Level angekommen, wo es ein bisschen schwierig wird. In.
Kanada stellen sie irgendwie fest, dass ein paar mehr Autos weggekommen sind in letzter Zeit.
Und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass die nicht, also die glauben zu wissen,
dass das mit dem Flipper Zero passieren würde.
Ein Flipper Zero ist ein wirklich cooles Kickstarter-Gerät. Ich habe das auch
und muss echt sagen, das ist einfach schön.
Also von der Hardware-Verarbeitung sehr wertig, die Software,
die da drauf ist, ist gut gemacht,
das ist halt eine gepflegte Community und hat ein, was hat der so, Bluetooth, NFC,
und auf bestimmten klassischen Frequenzen kannst du halt mitschneiden. Also...
Das ist so ein richtiges Hacker-Tool.
Hacker-Spielzeug kann man das wirklich nennen.
Das ist schon ein Werkzeug, weil es bringt sozusagen alle Basiskommunikationsfähigkeiten,
mit sich und macht nicht nur eine Sache, sondern ist halt so ein bisschen universeller
angelegt, um einfach...
Zu analysieren, auszuprobieren, einfach auch mal ein bisschen zu schauen,
wie funktioniert denn das jetzt hier eigentlich und ist insofern vollkommen vergleichbar mit,
Messgeräten, sag ich mal, aus der analogen Welt, nur dass du halt hier auch aktiv werden kannst.
Also was das Ding zum Beispiel machen kann, ist so schlecht gesicherte Systeme,
die einfach mit NFC arbeiten, wo man einfach nur so eine Karte irgendwo hinhält,
halt, ja, nach einem einfachen Standard, sowas kannst du halt schnell damit
mal kopieren und so eine Geschichten.
Also du kannst ältere so MyFair und sowas kannst du klonen,
Ultralight kannst du klonen, wenn du dann den Key dir vom Reader holst,
aber diese Angriffe waren, wenn du das vorher mit so einem,
Chameleon oder Proxmark oder sowas gemacht hast oder mit einem ganz normalen
NFC-Reader die Software für für Linux oder so, die ist dann schon relativ uncool.
Die war nicht so praktisch. Mit dem Flipper ist das wirklich super easy.
Hältst du an die Karte, hältst du an den Reader.
Macht in Hotels Spaß, nochmal ein Sicherheits-Backup von deinem Schlüssel zu machen.
Oder bei uns im Büro gibt es dann nicht so viele Chips für die Schranke unten. Weißt du?
Das ist besser, wenn du halt den Backup davon einfach Einfach im Firmen-Wiki
liegen hast, damit jeder mal schnell mit seinem Flipper da rein kann und solche Dinge.
Oder Garagen, alte Garagentore, wenn man da mal nicht so eine teure Fernbedienung
kaufen will. oder auch Infrarot.
Meine Beamer-Leinwand zum Beispiel, die geht mit Infrarot.
Da habe ich auch jetzt ein Backup von der,
Fernbedienung, von der Infrarot-Fernbedienung. Oder bis in irgendeinem Laden läuft ein Fernseher.
Nervt ja auch wie die Hölle. Dann kannst du schnell TV begonnen,
laufen lassen, Fernseher ausmachen und solche Sachen. Da geht schon einiges.
Das ist bestimmt auch im Flughafen, in diesen nervigen Irish Pubs und so weiter,
wo dann 30 Live-Übertragung von irgendwelchen Premier League Fußballspielen
sind, die keiner sehen will. Viel zu laut.
Das ist dann schnell aus. Ja.
Oder mal einen Ton runterdrehen hilft auch manchmal schon ein bisschen.
Aber bei Autos muss man wirklich sagen, dass also die neuen Autos werden gestohlen
über diese Keyless Go. Also du hast im Prinzip eine,
du hältst den also eigentlich Endlich versuchen die, der Schlüssel kommt dem
Auto nah und dann redet das Auto mit dem Schlüssel, handelt irgendwas aus und dann geht das Auto auf.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich Systeme, die die Reichweite des Autos im Prinzip erhöhen.
Die eine Seite hältst du an das Auto und mit der anderen suchst du dann in der
Nähe der Haustür mit einer Richtfunkantenne nach dem Schlüssel,
weil die meisten Leute halt ihren Autoschlüssel da haben, wo sie ihn brauchen,
nämlich beim Rausgehen vor der Tür.
Und dann kannst du halt sehr schön diese Autos halt zocken, indem du die Reichweite
von diesem Keyless-Go erhöhst.
Das kannst du mit so einem Flipper aber nicht ohne weiteres machen.
Da brauchst du schon noch ein bisschen mehr für. Also theoretisch denkbar,
dass ein Flipper dabei zum Einsatz kommt, aber der wird dir jetzt nicht fertig
geliefert als Keyless-Go-Diebding.
Oder bei älteren Autos kannst du tatsächlich für die Türanlage,
dass das Signal, mach mal die Tür auf, tatsächlich immer das gleiche ist.
Und dann könntest du theoretisch das mitschneiden und dann wieder nochmal ausschmieren.
Das ist aber ungefähr so, irgendwie in den 1990er haben die Autohersteller aufgehört.
Ich glaube, nur einige haben dann noch bis in die Mitte der 2000er noch geschafft,
so idiotische Systeme zu bauen.
Aber es ist auch tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht, mal mit dem Flipper halt
zu gucken, ob denn auch dein,
wenn du auf den Mach mal Tür auf Knopf drückst, wenn du das Signal nochmal sendest,
ob dein Auto dann noch aufgeht oder nicht. Genau.
Einfach um einzuschätzen, wie sicher ist denn eigentlich die Technik, die ich hier habe,
weil ein Auto zu haben, was man mal so eben mit irgendeinem Mitlauschvorgang,
bei den einfachen Systemen hat es halt im Prinzip ausgereicht,
wenn jemand sein Auto aufmacht, in dem Moment mal ganz kurz das mitzuschneiden,
was in dem entsprechenden Frequenzbereich abgeht.
Und dann, früher war das ja so, naja, niemand kam auf die Idee,
oder zumindest kamen die Autohersteller erstmal nicht auf die Idee,
dass sowas jemand tun wollen würde.
Warum sollte man das tun?
Naja.
Vor allem.
Weil die Technik, die man dafür braucht, damals halt wenig verfügbar und wenn
überhaupt nur teuer und schwer zu bekommen war.
Nur sehen wir ja, wie das eben vorangeht mit der Technologie und irgendwann
war das dann halt alles andere als schwer verfügbar und sehr billig auch noch zu machen.
Und jetzt hat man das eben so Handheld-Batterie betrieben, also eben in der
Hosentasche und könnte im Prinzip eben solche einfach gesicherten Sachen,
die ja eigentlich nur so Security by Obscurity sind,
ja, wir machen mal da irgendwas und wenn keiner zuhört, dann passiert da schon nichts.
Und heute sind diese Systeme eben kryptografisch dann auch etwas gehärtet und
arbeiten eben so und verhindern aber auch teilweise diese Verlängerung zum Beispiel,
indem sie dann wirklich mal die Signallaufzeit auch messen, dann sind solche
Angriffe eben auch schwieriger, also mindestens schwieriger,
wenn nicht sogar unmöglich.
Es gibt sicherlich immer wieder irgendeinen Weg drumherum und es ist ja immer
dieser Wettbewerb zwischen welchen Aufwand treibe ich jetzt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Kanada weniger Autos gestohlen bekommt,
wenn sie jetzt irgendwie den Verkauf des Flipper Zero einschränken.
Das ist einfach mal totaler Unsinn.
Also und was wird jetzt passieren? Jetzt werden in Kanada massenhaft Flipper
Zeros gekauft, bevor sie verboten werden und am Ende werden die Autos weiterhin
mit anderen Dingen geklaut.
Also es gibt tatsächlich, man erfährt ja relativ wenig drüber,
aber es gibt schon, wenn du so Angriffe hast auf so Car-Immobilizer,
da gibt es halt echt einen krassen Markt und da gibt es auch irgendwelche wirklich
halt von Hackern für Autodiebe gebauten Dinger, die halt sehr sehr teuer verkauft werden,
die echt nochmal ein bisschen besser in der Lage sind, auch neuere Dinge zu knacken.
Also da gibt es schon interessante Produkte, aber sicherlich nicht Flippers.
Naja, aber scheint also auch eine sehr unkluge Herangehensweise mal wieder zu sein.
Weil der größere Teil der Kunden, die so einen Flipper kaufen,
machen damit im Zweifelsfall Sicherheitsforschung irgendwie ein paar Spielereien.
Und mit Sicherheit klauen sie damit nicht massenhaft Autos.
Genau, Flipper Zero war auch in der vorletzten Freakshow Freakshow 2002 ein
Thema mit dem schönen Titel Sorgenfreie Intelligenz.
Interessant, das Ding gibt es schon seit Jahren also ich finde den fast schon
wieder langweilig aber dann die Freakshow Ich habe den zum Geburtstag bekommen
von meinen Freunden Was hast du für Freunde?
Ich habe gute Freunde, die schenken mir Flipper Zero zum Geburtstag beziehungsweise
den, wenn der Kickstarter klappt, dann kriegst du das Ding und,
dann war, glaube ich, anderthalb Jahre später oder so wurde der mir dann geliefert,
aber dadurch war ich einer der ersten, die einen hatten, weil die schön ihr
Handtuch da früh hingelegt hatten.
Toll.
Ja, toll, ne? Vielen Dank. Und eigentlich habe ich jedem einfach nur danach
so ein Auto geklaut und dann waren die auch happy.
Wir fahren jetzt alle BMW.
Ruckzuck refinanziert das Ding.
Ja, nicht ganz so gut hat es den Joshua Schulte getroffen.
Der wurde verurteilt zu 40 Jahren Gefängnis, weil er Hacking-Tools der CIA damals
an Wikileaks gegeben hatte.
Das war so diese Vault-7-Veröffentlichung.
Nach Angaben der US-Behörden ist das so der größte Diebstahl geheimer Daten
in der Geschichte der CIA und es waren halt einfach deren Hacker-Tools, die er, ja,
nachdem er dort zwischen 2012 und 2016 gearbeitet hatte, hat er halt deren ganzen
Hacking-Tools an Wikileaks weitergegeben und die haben den im März 2017 unter
dem Namen Vault7 veröffentlicht.
Ja, dafür geht er jetzt 40 Jahre im Knast, von 80 Geforderten.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt ja, Schaden sind hunderte Millionen Dollar,
weil er natürlich diese Tools verbrannt hat.
Und.
Motiviert war er wohl, irgendwie war er auf seine Kollegen sauer. Ja.
Dann hat er noch eine Reihe anderer Anklagen bekommen.
Besitz von Kinderpornografie, Falschaussagen, Spionage.
Ja, und der geht jetzt in den Knast.
Ich weiß leider gar nicht mehr so genau, wie sie den damals bekommen haben,
welchen Obstsäckfehler der begangen hat, dass sie ihn, aber der war relativ
schnell, waren sie dem habhaft geworden.
Vielleicht auch einfach nur, weil er nicht on good terms seine Abteilung da
verlassen hatte und dann haben sie den mal kurz geratzt.
Ja. Ja.
Wollte ich dir, um unserer Chronistenpflicht gerecht zu werden, hier erwähnen.
Das ist, ja dann warte mal, ich weiß gar nicht, die wievielte Wikileaks-Quelle
das jetzt ist, die mit schwerer Strafe versehen wird.
Die wievielte? Ja.
Also Chelsea Manning war ja so der erste Fall auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dazwischen noch andere waren. Wie.
Hieß diese Dame noch? Freedom? Das.
War keine Wikileaks-Quelle, die hat an Intercept Reality Winner,
hat an die Intercept geleakt und wurde,
wegen schlechten Quellenschutz, weil die Intercept die Datei einfach so wieder
online gestellt hat, ohne die mal von Metadaten zu befreien.
Bei dem World 7 League kann man allerdings auch sagen, also könnte man argumentieren,
dass der jetzt nicht unbedingt Whistleblowing war.
Da sind halt einfach mal die Attack-Tools
von der CIA nach draußen gehängt worden, was natürlich mitunter,
sehr unangenehme Konsequenzen für die CIA hat, wenn sie irgendwie Zugriffe verlieren
oder irgendwo nachgewiesen wird, dass sie es waren.
Man kann jetzt nochmal eine andere Diskussion darüber führen,
ob sie so etwas haben sollten.
Meine ethische Position dazu, dass staatliche Hacker irgendwie Sicherheitslücken,
zurückhalten, die dann für uns alle zum Risiko sind, ist bekannt.
Aber ich denke, die Veröffentlichung dieser Daten ist dann auf jeden Fall so im Bereich des,
schweren Schadens. Sagen wir mal, auf jeden Fall.
Kann man wohl sagen. Also so klug schien mir das jetzt nicht zu sein, der Move. Naja.
All right.
Dann hatte es sich schon angekündigt, wir haben es in der letzten Sendung behandelt,
dass die E-Privacy-Ausnahme durchgehen soll, durchs EU-Parlament ist sie dann auch.
Also da geht es um die sogenannte freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle.
Es war ja so, dass das, was mit der Chat-Kontrolle passieren soll,
eigentlich durch die E-Privacy-Regulierung der EU verboten ist.
Und deswegen mussten sie ja erst einmal diese Ausnahme von dem Verbot beschließen,
um dann in einem nächsten Rutsch quasi die Chat-Kontrolle richtig anzuordnen.
Das wiederum sieht jetzt nicht so aus, als wäre es ihnen gelungen.
Deswegen haben sie jetzt ihre alte Ausnahmeregelung, um das wenigstens freiwillig
zu erlauben, dass diese Überwachung wenigstens legal ist.
Die haben sie jetzt nochmal durchgekriegt und ja, die Abstimmung im EU-Parlament
ist irgendwie so 89 Prozent waren. waren 89% haben abgestimmt, 82% waren dafür.
Man kann sich anschauen, wer dagegen gestimmt hat und wer dafür gestimmt hat.
Aber ja, das ist auch hier eher so zur Chronistenpflichterfüllung erwähnt,
dass die jetzt verlängert wurde. Und ich glaube, um...
Wie lange war das denn jetzt? Ich glaube, um zwei Jahre oder so.
Da müsste ich jetzt nochmal schauen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie sich jetzt erstmal
wieder Sicherheit verschafft.
Ist aber ganz interessant zu sehen, welche Länder wie sehr dagegen gestimmt haben.
Da ist tatsächlich Deutschlands zweitstärkstes Land dagegen.
Tschechien noch ein bisschen mehr dagegen.
Jo. Und dann soll es eine Bundesdatenschutzgesetznovelle geben,
wo man sich auch fragt, warum eigentlich?
Und da gibt es irgendwie zwei Änderungen, die jetzt so ein bisschen Sorge machen.
Vor allem sollen Unternehmen also in die Lage versetzt werden,
dass sie ihre Datenschutzauskunftspflicht verweigern können mit der Begründung,
dass Geschäftsgeheimnisse betroffen wären.
Also du gehst jetzt zu so einem Unternehmen hin und sagst hier,
ich möchte mein Recht auf Datenschutzauskunft ausüben.
Schickt mal bitte alles, was ihr habt.
Und dann können die sagen, ne, das ist unser Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Also deine persönlichen Daten sind unser Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Das ist gut. Da muss man erstmal drauf kommen.
Und das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen übel, ne? Ja Und auch naheliegend, dass das,
missbraucht wird Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass so Leute beim Meta
sich denken, so Jo, genau so, genau so haben wir uns das gedacht,
Und das Ja, das also da wundert man sich,
Gleichzeitig ist schon klar, dass,
warum Juristen sagen, naja, okay, du kannst ein Unternehmen ja jetzt nicht zum
Verraten seiner Geschäftsgeheimnisse zwingen.
Nur die Frage ist, vielleicht sollten, sollte,
Sollten meine persönlichen Daten kein Geschäftsgeheimnis eines Unternehmens sein.
Also da werden eigentlich die Internetkonzerne einfach nur dazu eingeladen,
Datenschutz-Auskünfte demnächst einfach pauschal zu verweigern.
Weil wenn man dann sagt, was soll denn da ein Geschäftsgeheimnis sein,
dann sagen die halt, können wir nicht sagen, Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Naja, müssen sie immerhin nicht mehr das Urheberrecht bemühen. Ja.
Aber das ist schon wirklich.
Gibt jetzt andere Ausnahmen. Ja, wer will denn das überhaupt?
So steht das Gesetz jetzt da. Das andere, was da ein bisschen komisch ist,
dass jetzt so Scoring-Aktivitäten nicht mehr ordentlich Qualität sichern wollen.
Also unsichere Score-Werte, die irgendwie mit einer spärlichen Datenbasis hergestellt
werden, darf man also weiterverwenden.
Und es gibt keine externe Prüfung oder Zertifizierung der Zuverlässigkeit,
die irgendwie vorgeschrieben würde.
Also, oder es wird auch nicht geprüft, ob der Scoring-Wert systematisch irgendwie
diskriminiert nach Alter, Geschlecht oder so. Also es ist alles erlaubt.
Gibt im Prinzip keine Qualitätsanforderungen an Scoring-Werte.
Jetzt sagen natürlich die Score-Hersteller, naja die Qualitätssicherung ist
bei uns doch völlig klar.
Wenn unser Score nicht gut wäre, würden die anderen den ja nicht benutzen.
Klar. Wissen die ja auch.
Ja gut, ich meine, wissen sie vielleicht dann, wenn ein Ausfall nicht prognostiziert
wurde, ein Zahlungsausfall, aber dann trotzdem stattfand, dann können sie vielleicht davon ausgehen.
Aber die Leute, die gar keine Kredite bekommen haben, wissen sie ja nicht,
ob die sich hätten doch bezahlen können.
Genau.
Ähm, naja, und dann gibt's noch irgendwie Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum
durch Polizei und Behörden.
Wollen sie zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben zulassen?
Also, da ist ja auch wieder dieses Juristensprechen.
Natürlich darf die Polizei Videoüberwachung vornehmen, ja. Und dann wird aber
natürlich gesagt, zu welchem Zweck sie das darf.
Verhinderung schwerer Straftaten. Ich nehme jetzt ein Beispiel.
Es ist nicht so, ich will nur die Formulierung erklären, dass man Kompetenzen
der Polizei einräumt, zum Beispiel zur Verhinderung schwerer Straftaten oder
zur Strafverfolgung schwerer Straftaten.
Dann ist wiederum eine schwere Straftat definiert, da stehen dann welche Paragraphen
da referenziert sind und wenn du sagst, darf Videoüberwachung zur Erfüllung
ihrer Aufgaben, dann kannst du halt gucken, was sind die Aufgaben der Polizei,
was weiß ich, wenn jemand hinfällt, müssen sie dem helfen wieder aufzustehen,
ja, ein Freund und Helfer und dann sagst du halt, ah, alles klar.
Nee, nee, warum habt ihr hier eine Videoüberwachung gemacht?
Ja, zur Erfüllung unserer Aufgaben.
Und das ist natürlich ein sehr schwammiges und absolut unverhältnismäßig weitgehende
Beschreibung, weil dann müsstest du sagen,
also wann hat die Polizei denn jemals etwas nicht zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben gemacht? macht.
Ja, die Datenabfragen für ein NSU 2.0, ja, das war nicht zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben.
Ja, da könnte man jetzt sagen, da habt ihr wirklich, da habt ihr selbst die Latte noch gerissen.
Ja, vor allem, also...
Also die Vorstellung, dass die Polizei überhaupt irgendetwas tut,
was nicht zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben gedacht ist, so, ja, also ich meine,
macht ihr denn ab und zu auch mal was anderes außer der Erfüllung eurer Aufgaben?
Ja, so.
Das ist ja gut, ne?
Und das heißt einfach, genau, das heißt mit anderen Worten, Polizei darf das, Punkt.
Okay, das wäre doch was für den Hacker-Paragrafen, ne? Also Hacker dürfen ihre Tools benutzen.
Sodass sie ihre Aufgaben... Zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben.
Wieso brauchen Sie, wofür haben Sie den Flipper? Zur Erfüllung meiner Aufgaben. Ja.
Eben. Dafür ist es geeignet. So. Achso, ja, dann ist doch alles gut.
Ja, das ist, also das scheint irgendwie nicht in die richtige Richtung zu gehen.
Man fragt sich, also und jetzt, das ist jetzt der Kabinettsbeschluss.
Ja, also das ist der Entwurf eines ersten Gesetzes zur Änderung des Bundesdatenschutzgesetzes.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, Problem und Ziel. Warum?
Finde ich auch aber ganz gut, dass sie, wenn sie ein Gesetz machen,
in der Regel angehalten sind, mal zu erklären,
welches Problem sie meinen jetzt zu lösen. Und das ist jetzt der Kabinettsentwurf.
Wie gesagt, der kommt dann aus dem BMI ins Parlament herab und dann wird der da diskutiert.
Der vorliegende Gesetzesentwurf zielt im Kern darauf ab, erstens Vereinbarung
des Koalitionsvertrages zwischen der SPD, Grüne, FDP aufzugreifen.
Sowie Ergebnisse umzusetzen, die sich aus der Evaluierung des Bundesdatenschutzgesetzes ergeben haben.
Siehe den Bericht Evaluierung, den das BMI veröffentlicht hat.
Also die haben ihr eigenes Gesetz evaluiert und dann gesagt,
jetzt müssen wir was ändern.
Datenschutzkonferenz wird institutionalisiert und so weiter.
Hm, jetzt wird es doch ein bisschen
lang. Also okay, wir werden jetzt eine Bundesdatenschutzgesetznovelle
diskutieren, die wie viele Seiten hat?
Wir haben keine Seitenzahlen. Das sind auch, ne, 27 Seiten. Geht eigentlich
für eine Gesetzesänderung relativ einfach. Ja.
Die letzte Seite ist auch leer.
Ach so.
26. So viel ist jetzt auch nicht.
Und das ist ja nur, das ist dann auch die Begründung, ist dann wieder länger
als die einzelnen Änderungen.
Naja, vielleicht möchte ja eine, die uns zuhörenden,
Bundestags Mitglieder uns als Sachverständige da einladen. Da hätte ich mal Lust drauf wieder.
Echt? Das ist geil. Du liest irgendwie so. ich finde diese Gesetzesentwürfe immer ganz lustig.
Änderung des 10. Buches Sozialgesetzbuch. So, und dann steht da § 83 Absatz 1 des 10.
Buchs Sozialgesetzbuch Sozialverwaltungsverfahren und Sozialdatenschutz in der
Fassung der Bekanntmachung vom 18. Januar 2001.
BGBI das zuletzt durch Artikel 19 des Gesetzes vom 20.
Juli 2022 BGBL Bundesgesetzblatt ist das wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich nicht
BGBI, geändert worden ist, wird wie folgt geändert.
Erstens, in Nummer 2 Buchstabe A wird das Wort satzungsgemäßer durch die Wörter
von in öffentlich-rechtlichen Satzungen vorgesehenen ersetzt.
Folgender Satz wird angefügt. Das Recht auf Auskunft besteht auch insoweit nicht,
nicht als der betroffenen Person durch die Information ein Betriebs- oder Geschäftsgeheimnis
des Verantwortlichen oder eines Dritten offenbart würde und das Interesse an
der Geheimhaltung das Interesse der betroffenen Person an der Information überwiegt.
So, dann musst du dir das Buch rausholen und gucken, wo das steht.
Denk wirklich nach Spaß.
Das ist gut.
Ich verstehe richtig, dass du so scharf drauf bist.
Irgendwas von Mahnung haben sie auch Scoring, ah ja, Scoring das ist dann Mahnung Ja Ah, Paragraph,
37a BGB und 40a, ich glaube 38 ist so im Mindest oder sowas Ja,
Machen wir Nehmen wir gerne, gehen wir gerne hin.
Okay, ist ein Gesetzentwurf Da wird noch dran gefeilt werden Muss man auf jeden
Fall mal auf dem Zeiger haben.
Ja, also kommt mir ein bisschen komisch vor.
Vor allem habe ich jetzt noch nicht, mir fehlen die Fälle, also ehrlich gesagt, ne?
Klingt mir das so ein bisschen nach, die Lobbyisten von der Schufa haben ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Weil, wenn ich jetzt längere Zeit darüber nachdenke, wer hat denn Geschäftsgeheimnisse,
die durch Datenschutzauskünfte potenziell bedroht werden könnten?
Facebook.
Google, eigentlich nicht.
Aber so eine Schufa.
Das fällt eigentlich voll ins Feld, da hast du recht.
Und außerdem ist außerdem das Interesse der Schufa, dass Scoring und so weiter
möglichst frei diskriminieren kann, machen kann, wie es will und man nicht erklären
muss, wie es zustande kommt. kommt.
Und also laut Gesetzentwurf muss man nur die wichtigsten Kriterien,
so, und dann sagen die halt, die wichtigsten Kriterien sind,
wie nennt man das, dass man immer bezahlt, dass man seine Schulden bezahlt und dann sind die fertig.
Also ich glaube, da haben einfach die Lobbyisten von der Schufa ganz,
ganz gut bei Nancy Faeser vorgesprochen.
Also es wäre auf jeden Fall mal sehr interessant, mal nachzufragen,
was eigentlich die Motivation hinter diesen Änderungen genau ist.
Also was soll dadurch jetzt eigentlich wo besser werden und wäre auch mal eine
interessante Nachfrage mal zu schauen,
auf welche Branchen denn diese Änderungen denn irgendwelche Auswirkungen haben. Es.
Gibt die Evaluierung des Gesetzes zur Anpassung des Gesetzes.
Das ist das vom BMI, wo sie sagen, das was wir da gelernt haben, setzen wir hier um.
Das ist ein 143-seitiges Dokument.
Wir verlinken das mal. Das ziehen sie zumindest als Motivation heran,
dass hier jetzt Änderungsbedarf besteht. Jetzt können wir mal gucken.
Geschäftsgeheimnisse.
Äh, Geheimnis.
Geschäfts... Geschäftsgeheimnis kommt nicht. Nee, Geschäftsräume. Geschäftsstelle.
Also Geschäftsgeheimnisse steht ja schon mal nicht drin. In dieser...
Also dieses Dokument scheint sich nach meiner Wahrnehmung nicht unbedingt heranziehen zu lassen.
Als Begründung das einzubauen.
Tja, werden wir nächstes Mal erfahren. Wir gucken uns das nochmal an.
Auf jeden Fall werden wir jetzt offenbar diese BDSG-Novelle diskutieren dürfen
in den nächsten Sendungen.
Wie schön. Na gut, aber damit sind wir jetzt erstmal mit dieser Sendung durch.
Ja. Wir haben gewählt, wir haben gesendet.
Wir waren heute aber mal richtig gute Demokraten.
Aber sowas von. Vorbilder eigentlich, kann man sagen, oder? Ja.
Lupenrein in gewisser Hinsicht.
Lupenreine Vorbilder.
Super Typen.
Ich bin auch immer wirklich zufrieden mit mir. Heute bin ich richtig happy.
Ja, du bist so toll.
Ich bin stolz eigentlich.
Leute, das war's von uns. Wir entlassen euch in die Woche und hören uns dann
eine Woche drauf. In etwa wieder.
So werden wir das machen. Das.
Ist der Plan. Also wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald.